foreign
Trish is in Coeur d'Alene Idaho hi Trish
how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
good well I have a question I'll jump
right to it my father-in-law passed away
a year and a half ago and my husband and
his two sisters are the beneficiaries of
his estate
the one sister has been listed as the
executor and it took us until about a
month ago to even get a copy of his will
they claim that all of his assets have
been sold or gotten rid of or whatever
but they won't provide any accounting of
it and the only thing left is he had a
quite a gun collection that he was very
proud of and that was a big part of his
life and that he shared with his
children as far as an interest and love
of guns
so now these uh executor the sister is
insisting that these guns are going to
be sold on Saturday at a sale and she's
telling us that if we want to have any
of these guns that we have to pay the
price that she has listed them at
we have been through Financial Peace
University we're in baby step two we
have forty thousand dollars left of debt
to pay off and we have gotten fed up
with debt and we are at the point that
we don't borrow money
but as being a baby step two we only
have a thousand dollars in our emergency
fund and we just feel really stuck why
is his sister being a butt
I don't know I feel like they are hiding
things
and um and I don't know why well they
not get along I mean your brother or not
your husband not get along with his
sisters
they get along just fine except when
somebody died they did the same thing
when their mother passed away
but we're really torn that we have three
grown children
um two of them are sons and they would
really like to have some of these guns
of course they mean a lot to my husband
but financially we can't justify going
into debt to acquire these guns
I've reached out to like five or six or
two one-third of the guns are yours or
your husband correct
yes and that's what the will States is
that these assets are to be divided in
the third okay so as he told her no as
he told her you're not selling a third
of them I will come pick them up
yes and that was met with this
conversation was over and she hung up on
it okay
if I were your husband I would call it
depends on how much you wanted you got
two choices okay you stand back and
watch this happen or you hire an
attorney and you stop the sale and you
sue her ass
yeah
but then if we get go to the attorney
route I mean that's a lot of money too
no it's not
won't take a lot because this all this
woman needs is somebody just to give her
uh get her attention
that's what she needs no one has stood
up to this woman in a long time
and it is time somebody did okay but for
real though how much will it cost to get
an attorney to Trisha's point you know
it costs 200 to go get a letter and tell
her we're gonna you know might cost a
thousand dollars to file with the
probate court and stop the sale
but all you got to have is an attorney
listen all you got to have is an
attorney call her and this whole thing
is going to stop because she's she's
gonna cave like like a Walmart tent I
mean okay
that's another thing it's never gone
through
it doesn't have to necessarily
okay she has to follow you know the
executor is to follow the execution of
the will does the will state that the
assets are all to be sold at auction
it states that any any debts that he is
owing
um to sell assets to pay those deaths
and anything that's left to divide them
equally by the three children okay but
we don't know if there's debt left
well she won't say anything
on two other properties that have been
sold got no accounting of that either
yes they've been sold so it just depends
on how you know you either can just
forget it and walk away
and just forget it it's probably not a
lot of money it's probably not a lot of
money
well the guns the the value she's
assigned to them is about almost forty
thousand dollars it's not a lot of money
yeah forty thousand dollars divided by
three is not much
it's not going to pay for the attorney
by the time you have a big old fight
so you just got to decide how pissed you
are about this
well you're twisted up is your husband
oh my husband's emotionally Iraq okay I
mean like a wuss wreck or like like a
guy who's gonna stand up and do
something about it
well that's more what I'm afraid of
do something about do something about it
hire an attorney and shut her down put
them in junk go into a probate court put
an injunction on the sale until there's
an accounting of this stuff and that
because these assets need to be divided
if you want to spend a little money
fighting on it fight on it
okay but it's more about the fight than
it is and the Injustice of the situation
that is the actual amount of money
because I don't think there's a lot of
money here kiddo
no there's not but when we live our life
by saying we're not going to take out
any more debt ever yeah um and she's we
feel like we're being put in a position
where we would have to if we want to get
it you don't you don't have to accept
her terms I don't have to accept her
terms
okay just because you're going to get
some money from this estate and you can
pay the attorney with that money
there's money due to you there's money
due to your husband I know
yes
and but you don't know how much Trish no
we don't but no we don't know how do you
have a reasonable get okay what do you
think this property was worth is sold
he sold his house for 158 000 Russell
before he died by a few years
and then he owned another piece of
property that um conveniently got sold
to one of the sisters
okay you you you've either got to decide
you're going to accept the situation
you've got her an attorney this
afternoon
and you have to file with a probate
court to stop the sale tomorrow until
the executor is held to account
through an accounting of where the money
is freaking gone that's what I would do
because I don't put up with this trash
and this is just trash this is the
Ramsay show